Speaker 1: This story really hits home for
me. Many of you know this past year, I.
I was diagnosed with colon cancer. Still
very strange to say. Just a few months ago,
I under underwent surgery. They removed about 35%
of my colon. I'm healthy, a little fatter than I
probably should be, but overall, very healthy. I
have great blood pressure. All signs are great.
So cancer snuck up on me. And it is tough. Nobody
deserves it. If I wouldn't wish it on anybody,
it was a very rough road to recovery. I don't know
how to categorize it whether I almost lost my life
or I could have lost my life. But it was it was
close. Given, if not for my my wife's concern.
I might not be here given if not for her
convincing me to go to the doctor. I.
It would have been curtains for J.D.. So this
story does hit home for me. Jamie Raskin,
a beautiful man. Congressman from a neighboring
area right here in Washington, D.C., in Maryland
has been diagnosed with lymphoma
because I've just been introduced to two cancer.
I mean, it I don't know all the different kinds.
I don't know exactly which which which variety
of lymphoma he has. But he was in a committee.
And he has now a bandana on his head because
he's undergoing chemotherapy. And there was an
uncharacteristic and I think wonderful display by
James Colmer excuse me, the committee chairman.
And they're talking to him about how they're
going to pray for him and really show what an
outpouring of support uncharacteristic in these
political times. And I just I wanted to talk
about it and play it for you, because not only is
it beautiful and something we should strive for
to be able to work together. I think that if you
are a praying person, if you are a calm, a person,
if you are an energy person, if you are a
good vibes person, you should send them to
Congressman Jamie Raskin because he and his family
absolutely are in need of it. Watch this clip.
Speaker 2: I yield to the distinguished gentleman
from Maryland, ranking Member Jamie Raskin,
to introduce his members. But first,
I want to publicly say, Mr. Haskins,
we're all rooting for you. We
know that you're going to win
this battle if you're in our thoughts
and prayers. And it's good to see you
here today. I yield to Ranking Member Raskin.
Speaker 3: Mr. Chairman, thank you so much.
It means a lot to me, and I've been gratified
to receive so many kind words of encouragement
and sympathy from colleagues on both sides of
the aisle. And I hope that these expressions
of concern and solidarity will become seeds of
friendship over the year. I certainly plan on
getting through this thing and beating it, and
I thank you for your patience and indulgence
and.
Speaker 1: So listen.
Not only is Jamie Raskin a beautiful human
being, not only is he a talented and just
a fantastic lawyer and constitutional scholar
and expert, but he has a heart and a mind for
the American people. He is a patriot for
the country and a patriot for its people.
We need more like Jamie Raskin. We need more
Democrats like Jamie Raskin. And it would be.
An absolute tragedy to lose. Jamie Raskin as a
representative for Maryland. I mean, there's a
number of different directions we could talk about
now about Medicare. Medicare for all, universal
health care of whatever form in this country.
But I can tell you from firsthand experience
that we need a system change, a systemic change
in the way that we deliver health care in this
country. I'm sure he's getting the best of the
best care because he is a congressman. And his
the health care plans up there are Cadillac.
They are choice. I work for the Senate even,
and just as an employee. It was amazing
because we $20 for my son to be born.
But not everyone is as lucky. Even the medical
bills that my wife and I are facing right now are
racking up because of the surgery and the
treatment and everything else that went in
it. And I think that we need to be more mindful
and empathetic of others who are going through
something like this, who don't have the privilege
that Congressman Raskin has that I indeed have.
Anyway, thanks for indulge me a little personal
detour there. I appreciate you very much. If you
would like to subscribe to my YouTube channel,
you can go over just search my name. You can
find me on on the Internet, on social media. I
am at Dollar More, just about everywhere. And
of course, I host a twice weekly podcast with the
aforementioned Britney page. My wife and content
creator partner called I Doubt It Twice weekly
podcast. We love to see you there. Thanks a lot.